benoît hamon le porte-parole du parti
socialiste est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en ces temps difficiles pour le parti
socialiste même on peut dire pour tout
le pays sans doute apparemment les
français réagissent de la même manière
nouvelle qui est pas une bonne nouvelle
la chute de dsk comme titre l'ensemble
de la presse et des hebdomadaires cette
semaine qui pour sauver le parti
socialiste c'est le sujet qui sera
abordé tout à l'heure avec christine
coget de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire pour ce rendez vous à qui
succédera pour le dernier quart d'heure
de cette émission perrine tarneaud 2
public sénat pour des questions centrées
sur vous benoît hamon d'abord la droite
est elle dans le vrai quand elle pense
ou dit que l'espoir a changé de camp ça
montre qu'elle n'a jamais dire jamais
très éloignée de ses petits intérêts à
court terme la droite moi je veux vous
dire je pense que l'élection
présidentielle se jouera sur les
problèmes des français et on a bien
compris que aujourd'hui la droite
monsieur copé fillon nicolas sarkozy
voulait essayer par tous les moyens de
faire diversion de ce qu'étaient les
problèmes des français s'y livre
français votent en fonction de ce qu'est
leur situation et la manière dont elle
s'est dégradée depuis plusieurs années
ils ne voteront pas pour nicolas sarkozy
si ils devaient voter sur d'autres
sujets
s'il marchait dans cette diversion
effectivement pour imaginer que nicolas
sarkozy puisse être réélu la tâche qui
est la nôtre et c'est pour ça que même
dans ce moment de tourmente
incontestablement pour la gauche pour le
pays pour le parti socialiste
nous avons voulu maintenir le cap de ce
que sont et seront nos réponses sur le
logement la santé l'emploi le chômage
parce que c'est le plus important qu'un
parti politique qui s'il doit gérer les
crises et c'est une crise politique que
l'on vient incontestablement avec la
situation qui est celle de dominique
strauss kahn nous devons rester
ce que je vais appeler un maul de
stabilité lors de la révélation de ce
qui s'est passé à new york certains ont
évoqué un piège l'hypothèse du complot
vous parlez d'une diversion aujourd'hui
comme alternative vis versa le discours
de la droite qui dit à l'espoir a changé
de camp je vous dis que en règle
générale sa politique consiste à faire
diversion de ce que la situation réelle
des français et elle poursuivra dans
cette stratégie je vous fais pas de lien
entre la situation de ce qui s'est passé
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche et
aujourd'hui ce qui est le discours de la
droite en l'état je vous dis ce sera sa
stratégie
d'où l'importance pour nous de rester
sur l'essentiel c'est à dire de rester
sur les problèmes des français ils n'ont
pas disparu pourquoi parce qu'il ya un
événement tout aussi spectaculaire tous
aussi dramatique tragique soit-il
ces problèmes demeurent et un parti
politique doit y répond en tous les cas
on peut dire que les socialistes sont
dans la même situation que tous les
français benoît hamon est dans une
espèce de d'hébétude cet état de
sidération qui empêche parfois
d'ailleurs de là c'est de bien réagir ou
de bien réfléchir mais ce qu'il n'est
pas urgent aujourd'hui ce mercredi que
les socialistes tourner la page dsk
franchement écoutez c'est comme vous
allez quand même très vite ont besoin de
vous les médias
j'observe qu'à sound hebdomadaire avance
de vence leurs publications pour ne
donner aucune information nouvelle mais
sans doute aussi faire de belles
couvertures et l'argent qui va avec mais
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui nous
changerions la position que nous avions
hier et avant-hier vendredi va avoir
lieu une audition déterminante qui
établira probablement des faits nous
connaîtrons cette fois là la stratégie
de défense qui sera celle de dominique
strauss kahn nous saurons beaucoup plus
sur ce qui s'est passé réellement
il ya la plainte d'une femme qui dit
avoir été violée
c' est extrêmement grave les chefs
d'accusation sont extrêmement graves des
roms la montant des peines qui pourrait
toucher domique strauss kahn illustre la
gravité et nous avons conscience de la
gravité de ces faits mais d'ici vendredi
il y avait une stratégie que votre cas
une stratégie une réponse de la part des
avocats de dominique strauss kahn et lui
même s'étaient de nier les faits et à ma
connaissance ils tous il nie toujours
les faits et bien nous serons vendredi
si les faits établis
une vérité qui doit amener à remettre en
cause la version d'untel ou d'unetelle
je dis juste parce que je sais sur ces
questions il ya de l'émotion qui
s'exprime et j'étais à mes yeux elle est
parfaitement légitime
je n'oublie pas à dire je crois l'avoir
dit mme régulièrement nous n'oublions
pas que dans cette affaire la première
victime et la plaignante
vous vous l'avez peut-être dit plutôt
que d'autres il ya une réunion libre âge
de la parole des amis de dominique vous
pouvez pas nier avec par exemple quand
jack lang trouve incompréhensible que
dsk reste en prison car il n'y a pas
mort d'homme tout de même j'ai lancé
commencé quand j'ai agi seul et je
trouve que cette expression est déplacé
malvenu et qu' il faut retenir de que
dans cette affaire il y a pour nous une
émotion de voir un homme que nous
connaissons pour certains d'entre eux de
nom de mes amis politiques
personnellement depuis dix quinze vingt
ans avec lesquels ils ont partagé des
combats politiques se sont investis le
voir dans cette situation provoque une
émotion qui d'émotion compréhensible
légitime vis à vis de quelqu'un que l'on
voit transporté au coeur d'une scène qui
étaient jusqu'ici réservées aux séries
télévisées et au cinéma américain et
cette scène là à choquer c'est pas parce
qu'elle choque que cette émotion
submerge ce qui est le sens pour nous
des réalités le sens des réalités c'est
d'abord de se souvenir qu'il ya une
femme qui a peut-être été victime d'une
tentative de viol
si c'était s'est fait est établi ce
serait extrêmement grave parce que c'est
un crime extrêmement grave jean françois
copé oppose la retenue de l'ump sur dsk
aux propos de haine dit-il sur woerth
et encore alliot marie que lui répondez
vous je vois que il est dans le calcul
politique souvenez vous que nous posions
des questions que monsieur woerth avait
menti devant l'assemblée nationale que
madame alliot marie avait elle même
menti et que au bout du compte dans ses
affaires quand nous posions des
questions etc ont refusé de nous
répondre on était dans le déni
soi-disant dans la chasse à l'homme le
lynchage l'acharnement et c'est qu'on
associés d'ailleurs les médias aux
socialistes dans cette affaire nous nous
sommes contentés de faire ça pour
démontrer ensuite que manifestement il y
avait un problème au point que monsieur
woerth soit écartée du gouvernement par
monsieur sarkozy
donc je vois bien où veut en venir jean
françois copé et je ne mets à la phrase
qui a été que l'on prête que l'on prêté
hier dans le monde à nicolas sarkozy
vous avez faire bien le moral de la
morale je veux vous dire jusque bon de
la part de nicolas sarkozy ça pourrait
prêter à sourire quand on sait les
mélanger les conflits d'intérêts qui ont
émaillé la totalité de son mandat quand
on se souvient de la gestion de la
révolution du printemps arabe mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il a un tout petit peu
corrigé le tir depuis mais il n'a pas
fallu longtemps pour que les snipers de
l'ump jean françois copé en tête
reprennent leurs fusils leurs lunettes
et tirades unis surveillent ce sera
difficile à l'avenir peut-être plus
difficile pour les socialistes d'adopter
une posture morale sur tel ou tel sujet
et pourquoi donc et sur quoi même si les
snipers ils sont la règle et 0 on les
vire mais les snipers ont une quelconque
crédibilité qu est ce qu est ce que vous
avez approché par exemple porte-parole
pas de socialistes en matière d'aidé
lundi dernier une femme victime mais je
peux importe où parti social en tant que
nous en tant que parti politique à
martine aubry à ses dirigeants qu'il ya
on est là il ya un problème il ya une
question qu'on ignorait qu est planqué
sous votre tapis ou sous cette table
qu'on y aurait je crois pas donc je dis
juste que pour nous la question centrale
elle est pas de répondre comme je viens
de le faire eux maintenant à ces
attaques
elle est de se concentrer sur ce qu'est
la faille l'échec la lacune le trou
béant du bilan de nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui vont mieux les riches
aujourd'hui vont moins bien les classes
moyennes les classes populaires le
salariat les retraités il ya tout cela
se souviendront au moment du vote à qui
ils doivent le fait qu'ils ont un
enregistrement vous avez cité des
couches populaires
un benoît hamon ce n'est pas vous faire
injure de lui faire injure non plus
rater ce cas de rappeler que c'était pas
votre tasse de thé un dsk politiquement
peut le dire on peut le rappeler sans
lui sans ces soutiens sans lé tro scania
de la fondation terra nova
auteur d'une note controversé le parti
socialiste va t'il donc songer un peu
plus désormais à l'électorat ouvrier et
populaire en signe questions importantes
un tout petit problème c'est pas une
chose vous dit c'est pas ma tasse de thé
nous n'étions pas de la même sensibilité
j'étais avec lui il ya une dizaine de
jours puisqu'il avait demandé à me voir
quand on était venus sur paris nous
avions eu un échange d'ailleurs assez
passionnant sur la question du libre
échange de la mondialisation de ce
qu'était l'état de la france et dieu
sait qu'elle va me faisait mal mais
séduit mais on n'était pas dans ses
idées participent mais je pense que
c'est ce qu'ils pendant six mois je
pense qu'on était on est des camarades
dans le même parti donc on se parle on
veut retrouver pour vous rapprocher
l'art mais vous savez la socialiste va
voter socialiste au premier tour des
élections présidentielles il y avait une
primaire avant il aurait pu être
candidat il ne l'était pas je veux juste
vous rappeler qu on tire un trait
aujourd'hui sur quelqu'un qui n'avait
jamais dit être candidat et qui avait
dit qu'il discuterait avec martine aubry
de cette possibilité en répétant
publiquement qu'elle était la plus
légitime
eq si elle était candidate il ne le
sauraient pas quand vous l'avez
rencontrée mais quand il a multiplié
lundi les propos avaient été rapportées
par plusieurs personnes dont il les
assume et cela devant les rédactions
elle s'est présentée quand même il ya un
mois maintenant comme l'homme
providentiel 1 pour la gauche et pour la
france c'est assez logique qu'il s'y
préparait mais c'est une personne ne
doutait de sa mais même s'il s'y
préparer il a pris soin systématiquement
de dire et de rajouter que l'idée qu'ils
savaient de la responsabilité la veille
à penser que martine aubry était la plus
légitime et qu'elle s'il se présentait
il ne se présenterait pas je dis juste
ça parce que d'accord j'ai maintenant
mais c'est marrant à la question de
savoir de quelle façon aujourd'hui on
considère qu'il était même pas candidat
à la primaire mais d'ores et déjà
candidats élus mais aussi presque
d'accord
ce qui pose et benoît hamon je vous pose
la question sous une autre forme
le conseiller de nicolas sarkozy très
controversé parce que il vient de
l'extrême droite patrick buisson a
évoqué récemment la prolophobie de la
gauche mondaine et parisienne qu'il ne
voyait pas juste quand on a vu tomber
cette note de terra nova qui a dû vous
faire bondir mais parce que c'est pas le
parti socialiste
à nova c'est un think tank qui est un
think tank animée par quelques
socialistes ils ont le droit de le leur
qui travaille avec des sociétés privées
qui produit mais c'est pas la boîte à
idées du parti socialiste
avez vous vu dans le projet socialiste
une analyse de la société qui considère
qu'il faille faire l'impasse sur les
classes populaires au motif qu'elle
aurait aujourd'hui une sorte d'identité
politique populiste
une culture qu'ils soient éloignés du
projet social démocrate non non via
terra nova prenant l'analyse du m23
servira-t-elle à d'autres candidats mais
je peux sans m'avancer beaucoup dire
mais c'est pas cette analyse qui servira
de base à la stratégie qui sera celle du
candidat socialiste nous nous
considérons aujourd'hui que les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
partagent une communauté de destin
pourquoi parce qu'elles vivent les mêmes
problèmes
amelio augmentation de la souffrance au
travail conditions de travail qui se
dégradent déclassement salaires qui
n'augmentent pas pouvoir d'achat qui
baisse que ça concerne un employé un
ouvrier ou un cadre moyen où les classes
moyennes et les classes populaires
cette communauté de destin les
rassembler et bien c'est à eux que nous
voulons parler ensemble sont distingués
ce que sont les classes populaires des
classes moyennes et en oubliant que la
plupart d'entre eux sont des salariés
des producteurs des petits artisans si
des petits chefs d'entreprise qui
partagent tous les mêmes conditions
d'existence et toujours souvent les
mêmes inquiétudes pour leur avenir et
celui de leurs enfants
donc voilà écoutez très bien qu'ils
produisent des notes
et je peux même vous dire que je ne
pense pas que cette note là aurait servi
de base à dominique strauss kahn
d'accord d'accord anthony cas dominique
strauss kahn se voyait je vous le disais
un comme l'homme providentiel de la
gauche et de la france il l'avait dit
notamment à nos confrères de libération
c'était lors de ce fameux déjeuner du 28
avril il avait confié à nos confrères
ces trois qualités selon lui la
compétence la dimension internationale
et le calme
on se dit c'est pas facile à remplacer
mais si vous prenez les mêmes qualités
bien d'autres qualités et à d'autres
qualités c'est le tempérament
oui c'est le sens des responsabilités ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il en avait pas mais
je sais d'autres candidats aux
candidates qui présenteront des qualités
qui sont des qualités indispensables
pour faire face à la crise et ne pas
répondre à la crise que la réponse ou la
solution à la crise et demander
davantage de sacrifices aux français
notre priorité ce sera plus la minorité
comme c'est le cas depuis cinq ans mais
le sort de la majorité son avenir assuré
le parti socialiste sera au rendez vous
de 2012 martine aubry il ya quelques
jours jugé utile de le rappeler
benoît hamon christine poujoulat celle
ci comprenant ou non mais c'était une
petite dépêche à l'incidence est une
pause et donc de la lfp va nous
rejoindre pour pour bell pour poser la
question est ce que par exemple une
martine aubry qui multiplient autour
d'elle les soutiens en ce moment peut
être sont les solliciter est-elle
doit-elle se déclarer qui pour sauver le
parti socialiste qui pour 2012 sachant
donc aujourd'hui cas de force majeure
martine aubry est libéré de son pacte
michaël szames est ce un taux retrait
les soutiens de martine aubry retrouve
le sourire et se prennent désormais
espérer élus dirigeants
il se range désormais derrière la
première secrétaire convaincue qu'elle
portera au mieux les couleurs de la
gauche effectivement elle elle
représente aujourd'hui notre
rassemblement et même d'une certaine
manière un potentiel de rassemblement de
la gauche martine aubry elle ne veut pas
bousculer le calendrier du parti
socialiste
même si selon ses amis elle donnera des
signes dans les prochaines semaines en
attendant la première secrétaire donne
rendez vous aux électeurs
je le dis très simplement aux français
nous serons au rendez-vous de 2012 le
parti socialiste sera là sur la ligne de
départ les candidats à la primaire sont
déjà nombreux après cette affaire dsk
françois hollande est passé du statut de
challenger à favori mais pour lui pas de
changement de stratégie aux perspectives
pour ségolène royal et arnaud montebourg
les vents des sondages ne sont pas
porteurs mais ils n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot
je suis très optimiste sur le fait que
nous avons en nous les ressources pour
maintenant nous rassembler reste une
question que feront les amis de
dominique strauss kahn pierre moscovici
pourrait lui aussi être tenté par
l'aventuré comme d'autres
laurent fabius pourrait lui aussi se
positionner comme un possible recours à
la crise et une pochette avec nos
christine bonsoir votre question on se
faire christine coget alors martine
aubry donc son pacte est caduque
defacto avec dsk et est ce qu'elle est
obligée d'y aller
rien ne l'obligeait candidate à
l'élection présentielle
vous savez je crois que martine aubry a
résonné de la manière suivante depuis le
départ elle a conscience que nous avons
une immense responsabilité c'est que
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre le
luxe ou le drame de cinq ans de mandat
de nicolas sarkozy supplémentaires une
pause cela il faudra avoir remplir
toutes les conditions pour pouvoir
gagner mettre les chances de notre côté
et elle avait dit dès le départ je ne
considère pas une fois que j'ai dit ça
que je suis là solution parce qu'elle ne
croit pas à l'idée qu'une seule personne
serait la solution et qu'il faudra vont
reconstruire la gauche rassembler le
parti socialiste rassemblé la gauche qui
est une étape encore à conquérir pour
être en situation ensuite de pouvoir
proposer le ou la meilleure d'entre
elles incluent est d'ailleurs dans cette
discussion ségolène royal bertrand
delanoë
parmi les candidats potentiels laurent
fabius et tous les ce qu'ils voulaient
se pose présenter sur la ligne de départ
l'idée qu'elle s'est fait de la
responsabilité c'était cela et
aujourd'hui elle est exactement dans
même état d'esprit je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure elle n'avait pas décidé si elle
serait candidate il
la semaine dernière dominique strauss
kahn non plus ils se préparaient
ensemble ils discutaient ensemble avec
d'autres la question de savoir si elle
le sera se fera en fonction des mêmes
critères
pense-t-elle à ce moment là qu'elle est
la meilleure chance pour la gauche et le
parti socialiste de battre nicolas
sarkozy pensez vous
moi je les dis je c'est un secret de
polichinelle j'ai jamais plana
aujourd'hui son devoir mais je parlerai
encore pas entendre de devoir une
obligation ni de devoir mais il ya là
pas de devoir nous nous avons un devoir
collectif elle a pas le devoir elle de
se l'offrir son intelligence à au
socialisme et au peuple français c'est
pas comme ça que je conçois les choses
je pense que elle est la mieux à même
aujourd'hui à la fois de porter un
projet qui sur la question sociale qui
sera la question centrale qui correspond
à la demande la plus évidente des
français je veux dire quand ils nous
arrêtent ils nous disent quoi que le
pouvoir d'achat baisse pourquoi parce
que les salaires n'augmentent pas que
les dépenses incompressibles
elle ne cesse d'augmenter qu'ils ont de
plus en plus de mal à se soigner pour
des gens qui n'avaient jamais imaginé
avoir ce type de problèmes que
contrairement aux fables du ministre
chatel c'est de plus en plus difficile
aujourd'hui d'avoir des classes dans
laquelle on a des profs enfin de soi
mais je dis pourquoi elle le fera si
j'explique c'est la responsabilité c'est
pas voilà ça tombe pas du ciel c'est
parce qu'il ya une situation qui est
extrêmement alarmante et qui suppose
qu'on ait une femme qui rassemble de
tempérament et qui soit en capacité pas
simplement de conquérir le pouvoir mais
demain dont on va dire ce qu'est le
spectre des contraintes ce que sera le
rapport de force de changer en
profondeur l'organisation de ce pays
comme de solidarité termes de lien
social de rémunération du travail
d'accès aux services publics et sa
supposera de la force
est-ce qu'elle en a réellement envie de
mouiller à ces regards sur moi je suis
j'ai officié de réponse fabius a une
très belle formule je la reprends il
deale envie c'est pour le chocolat et
et bon nicolas sarkozy avait très envie
ben nous on a maintenant aussi très
envie qu'il s'en aille parce qu'il avait
très envie d'être président on n'a pas
eu l'impression que cette envie il a
sans doute jouit de sa fonction il en a
profité
il en avait très envie il en a beaucoup
profité maintenant il faut on attend
après on entend le mandingue qui a le
sens de l'intérêt général l'intérêt
général c'est de prendre les problèmes
de regarder là où se situe l'intérêt du
plus grand nombre
l'intérêt du pays de la nation et pas
considéré que l'intérêt de la nation
c'est toujours l'intérêt des petits
copains voilà quand est-ce qu'elle doit
se déclarer alors à votre avis est-ce
qu'il faut qu'elles attendent je veux
dire le désigner les grands dire si elle
est candidate elle est candidate
il ya un calendrier qui court jusqu'à la
mi juillet une leçon et elle vous
donnera sa décision moi j'ai pas de
conseil à lui donner
observons d'abord c'est difficile de
parler de ça alors qu'on est en même
temps dans la tente de d'informations
supplémentaires sur ce qui pourrait se
passer à new york dominique strauss kahn
dort en prison c'est rien de le dire
j'ai l'impression d'être dans une
fiction donc voilà donc je sais pas on
n'a pas parlé de ça avec martine aubry
on a on n'est pas dans ce calendrier là
elle a voulu tenir le cap elle était à
bordeaux hier devant plus d'un millier
de personnes parler du projet elle a
mesuré ce qu'était la demande latente le
trouble de nos propres électeurs elle
était aujourd'hui pour parler en ciment
supérieur recherche à toulouse elle a
visité des labos par les notes
politiques de renseignement de
d'éducation d'investissement dans la
recherche en politique pour les seniors
qui semblait plus que sur le terrain tu
en parles tu
non mais ça s'est passé qu'elle est sur
le terrain comme une formule où voilà il
faut le sait pas et figures imposées
effectivement nos dit mais elle est là
où aujourd'hui les français attendent
plus qu'une posture et un discours ils
attendent des réponses est néanmoins
françois hollande est largement devant
dans les sondages désormais c'est un
problème un handicap mais vous savez il
est françois hollande est candidat lui
dit qu'il va aller jusqu'au bout il a
montré très vite son envie juste mais
écoutez du chocolat j'étais la
présidence explique françois hollande
pour des beaucoup de raisons et parmi
celles là le fait qu'il est un candidat
qui défend ce samedi dès qu'il les met
dans le débat qui les actifs
voilà qui multiplie les réunions il
était premier secrétaire du parti
maintenant ma mon ma conviction c'est
que martine aubry elle n'est pas encore
candidate
donc on mesure dans les sondages des
gens qui sont candidats avec des gens
qui n'ont pas dit et pour avoir une
petite expérience dans le domaine des
études d'opinion professionnels
et je mesure je pense que vous même si
vous regardez tout petit peu
sérieusement ce que disent les études un
an avant l'élection présidentielle
il ya arrêtons chaque semaine de nous
sortir des études contradictoires en
pensant que c'est la vérité du moment
quoi voilà malgré tout quand même dsk je
veux dire s'il avait été candidat enfin
il était quand même une espèce de
rempart contre l'éparpillement des
candidatures des deux candidatures
multiples secondaire et c est ce que
vous pensez pas qu avec cet empêchement
plus que probable va pas y avoir une
multiplicité de candidatures et ça va
ramener imagine de supprimer par exemple
les primaires c'est claude bartolone qui
soutient comme vous martine aubry que
pensez vous de cette idée je la pense
que le réflexe des socialistes
aujourd'hui je crois que ça va produire
des résultats durables va au
rassemblement qu'est ce qui vous fait
penser ça les discussions que j'ai avec
mes amis les discussions que j'ai avec
aston deux candidats je pense que c'est
aujourd'hui ou le les entourages vous
savez on n'est pas dans des écuries
cloisonné totalement séparés françois
hollande on se parle on téléphone
ségolène royal on se voit on se parle
tout le monde se parle c'est à dire qu'
il n'y a pas trois ou quatre partis
socialistes parallèle sa pu exister au
congrès de reims était le cas c'était
très difficile de se parler on a vu pour
quel résultat
aujourd'hui les socialistes plus les
chiens on se rapproche plus il se parle
je pense que c'est bien et avec la
situation que nous vivons qui était
imprévisible
sami la présente vous avez utilisé tout
à l'heure et le plus juste c'est la
sidération c'est à dire que c'est comme
si on avait perdu le contact avec le
réel on est d'où le fait qu'on bascule
dans l'irrationnel qu'on imagine des
scénarii des conjurations des
conspirations par non ddd complot autres
qu'on imagine qu'ils développent sur
internet dans l'opinion
bon mais on est aussi dans ce moment là
et moi je me posais des questions sur
l'avenir
je peux vous assurer qu en ce moment mon
quotidien comme porte parole du parti
socialiste
il est pas encore à bâtir des
plans sur la comète les décrire à
l'avant cette unité qui dépend très
largement l'univers renforce se renforce
dans cet état de choc
au point d'imaginer de se passer des
prix mais non
pour vous c'est clair veut dire il y
aura les primaires le calendrier sera
respecté
oui et oui oui oui et je veux dire vous
ne pensez pas que ça pourrait évoluer
l'un dans le mois qui viendra sous la
pression amicale des uns et des autres
je vois aucun événement proche ou à
venir qui justifie cela ou alors on
monte en disant cela on peut toujours je
peux toujours être contredit par par un
événement exceptionnel mais mais je
crois que notre tâche dans un moment
comme celui là surtout quand ça quand il
a groove en gros temps c'est de garder
leurs antennes
l'objectif c'est ma oui mais tu es
obligé vous n'êtes pas obligé de prendre
une trajectoire en général en bateau
surtout pas utile il vient vous même
vous aviez dit d'ailleurs que vous iriez
peut-être si dsk y aller quand est il là
maintenant j'avais dit peut-être jamais
mideci aujourd'hui pas plus qu'hier jeu
je suis candidat à la primaire d'accord
mais ça peut quand même éveillé d'autres
d'autre envie d'y aller on pense par
exemple à laurent fabius se dirait
paraît qu'il a reçu des milliers de
mails donc voilà on se pose la question
ils étaient un peu sorti des écrans
radar des sondages l'envoi qu'il est
très bon mais est-ce que alors qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ce que je sais de
ce que je connais de lit encore nous pas
pro intimes mais je trouve que je ne
crois pas que ce soit sa pente c'est pas
trés ce serait pas très cohérent avec ce
qu'il a pu jusqu'ici dire le rôle qu'il
a pu jouer
il est aujourd'hui une autorité
incontournable dans le parti socialiste
est il la joue un rôle déterminant comme
un un élément de stabilisation du parti
socialiste et je crois qu'il continuera
si je joue vraiment collective c'est ça
oui stabilise le parti socialiste il est
une autorité dont nous avions besoin
jeudi quand je dis nous je pense tous
les candidats aux primaires compris et
on devrait saluer le rôle qu'il a joué
depuis plusieurs mois pour stabiliser le
parti socialiste mais semble-t-il ranger
derrière la stature de dsk rhin qu'il
apportait son soutien et cette stature
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'il la
retrouve chez les autres candidats aux
primaires par exemple j'ai lu que à
propos de martine aubry dise qu'elle n'a
pas le langage présidentiel
mais vous savez ils n'auront pas les
mêmes qualités mais c'est pas
aucun d'entre eux n'a les mêmes qualités
donc ils sont pas interchangeables
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y aura qu'un
candidat présentiel qui sera choisi en
fonction sans doute de ses qualités mais
aussi du projet qu'il porte ce pour vous
assurer que l'électorat qui viendra
voter aux primaires sont les électeurs
pour la plupart socialistes ou de gauche
ils viendront en fonction
désir de gagner de la envie de gagner
pro ce qui les concerne
mais aussi en fonction de ce qu'ils
croient être les arguments
indispensables pour gagner et ils seront
attentifs à ce qu'on dira sur l'avenir
de la fonction publique ils seront
attentifs à ce qu'on dira sur la lutte
contre les délocalisations
ils seront attentifs à ce qu'on dira sur
la manière de lutter contre les
licenciements sur le fait qu'on réduise
l'échelle des salaires
si on peut concrètement augmenter les
salaires
minima sociaux sur l'avenir des
retraites c'est les questions qui nous
poserons c'est aujourd'hui beaucoup nous
parle mais qui va être votre candidat
mais la question qui précède ou la
question qui suit immanquablement seo
mais au fait
sur les 60 ans sur la question de la
santé sur la question de la vie à deux
de mes enfants quand un chef
d'entreprise une pme vous dit sûr mais
sur les impôts ça m'intéresse vous que
vous baissiez parce que je réinvestis
il s'est immanquablement il rend ils
reviennent à leur situation individuelle
et puis aussi à la volonté que la france
retrouve son aile a perdu depuis
quelques années où en sont vos
discussions avec les partenaires de la
gauche plurielle j'avais aussi une
question un peu sur se poursuivre
il ne se poursuivre nous ferons un point
bientôt sur ces discussions nous
souhaitons et nous nous engagerons à la
fois sur le fond avec nos partenaires a
avancé sur un ensemble de sujets on va
dire très simple on peut avec les verts
avancer sur la question du financement
de la solidarité
on va ensuite avoir omni la politique
énergétique
au parti socialiste on a entre
poursuivre ce débat il n'est pas finie
mais nous aurons là un sujet qui est un
sujet on fera l'inventaire de ce qui
nous rassemble c'est aussi ce qui
continue à faire divergences mais
l'objectif est bien d'arriver à un socle
commun sur lequel l'ensemble des
formations de gauche puissent se
retrouver et je vais vous dire ce qui
les réunit les formations de gauche
c'est quoi c'est le progrès
c'est comme en france si la marche du
progrès s'était interrompue depuis
maintenant de trop longues années vient
nous voulons ensemble reprendre la
marche du progrès nous pouvons le faire
avec la volonté de redistribuer les
richesses de lutter contre les
inégalités ça n'empêche ni la modération
ni la tempérance et notamment vis-à-vis
du milieu naturel c'est de l'écologie
sur mêlant chant justement est-ce que
avec le possible retrait de dsk est ce
que ça va faciliter aux discussions avec
mélenchon justement côté c'est pas moi
je suis pour discuter avec mélenchon de
toute façon voilà donc
de toute façon je ne mets pas de
préalable à sa discussion je lui dis pas
nous voulons discuter avec toi à
condition que que que peut-être on m a
t'il lui mais moi je n'en mets pas pour
l'instant de préalables et nous disons
nous voulons discuter avec le parti de
gauche parce que nous aurons besoin du
front de gauche dans sa totalité des
écologistes pour rassembler la gauche et
demain gagné les élections
présidentielles donc marc non merci
christine avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud une question une réaction à
jean françois copé lui il est contre les
primaires socialistes libération
attention et il dit à langer dangers
qu'il ya peu de goût pour la démocratie
d où l idée attention il ya danger
il évoque de possibles pressions des
maires socialistes sur sur leurs
subordonnés par exemple leur s'employer
pour les inciter à aller voter c'est le
secrétaire général nommé par nicolas
sarkozy de l'ump
va trouver toutes sortes de à inventer
toutes sortes de légendes toutes sortes
d'histoires pour expliquer au départ que
c'était illégal
je sais bien ça qu'il avait dit donc ce
n'est pas illégal sont bien d'accord
voilà donc encore une histoire ça s'est
réglé maintenant les maires ferait
pression sur les employés pour qu'ils
viennent voter même leurs administrés
allez savoir
voilà pourquoi il est comme une écoute
et tout ça est ridicule
moi j'aimerais que jean françois copé
deux secondes à la france plutôt qu'à
ses petites histoires et puis s'il a un
problème avec la démocratie sur sa
triste de la part du patron de l'ump à
l'héparine dont va nous rejoindre
on va devoir découvrir benoît mans
différentes facettes de votre
personnalité
et oui en entrant d'abord discrètement
dans votre bureau rue de solférino ce
matin ah oui bah justement on appelait
on a pu pousser la porte visites guidées
seuil est à mme tran huy rue de
solférino à quelques encablures de
l'accueil rez de chaussée à droite on
pénètre dans le bureau de benoît hamon
rentrer chez le porte parole du parti
socialiste c'est un peu comme pénétrer
dans la loge de la concierge dit si on a
une vue panoramique sur les allées et
venues rien ne lui échappe
ambiance studieuse et plutôt modestes
entre les unes des quotidiens
on observe des notes de travail pour
préparer les entretiens médias
consciencieux benoît hamon mais quand on
passe les murs en revue on découvre ce
que le porte parole du ps veut bien
montrer de lui d'abord les symboles
politiques et les figures tutélaires
ici on n'échappe pas au culte de
françois mitterrand ni à celui de jaurès
ou encore léon blum les affiches
d'époque de la sf you en face du bureau
benoît hamon n'oublie pas le passé de la
gauche en bonne place le compagnon de
toujours
henri emmanuelli et last but not least
barack obama au passage on note l'humour
à la benoît hamon l'ex socialiste est
super retraite rik besson traîne sur les
étagères figé dans un cadre en plastique
enfin les passions personnelles le
rugbymen est un peu partout l'amoureux
du foot aussi le féministe enfin
mais la facette qu'il dévoile le plus
volontiers de lui c'est le breton
l'écusson trône à sa gauche
les fier et têtu comme un breton
paraît-il de têtu c'est vrai qu'ils ont
enlevé des photos à lesquelles celle de
ma fille vient pour commencer puis 2-3
que qui on l'avait plus de la blague je
garde pour moi donc
donc avant notre visite vous avez enlevé
cherche une photo oui je suis préfère
être détruits cliché mais le besson je
les laissais c'est vrai qu'elle est la
femme est sacrément rancune on regarde
notre carte de visite hier les ont créés
par hasard au sens où j'étais c'est le
savez on a déroulant à côté de son
bureau et dg ouvert et il y avait les
cartes de visite d'eric besson quand il
était secrétaire national je trouvais ça
marrant j'ai fait des petits cadres à
dispo j'avais mis dedans puis ça nous
rappelle très sûrs d'eux jamais basculé
à droite pour vous oui je pense très
menacés mais on ne sait jamais vous avez
quand même laissé dans votre bureau pour
punta de visite ce matin cette photo de
vous sur ce fond bleu parce que c'est un
cadeau que vous centrez non mais non
mais si en plus c'est une photo que qui
me rappelle le congrès
et qui était une photo aussi on a belle
aventure humaine politique et pour le ps
ou hip hop us moyens ben oui mais nous
c'était moi mes amis ceux qui défendront
nos idées en matière de lutte contre le
libéralisme le libre échange pour la
redistribution n'a vécu que ça comme une
aventure
quand même positive constructive même si
le bilan pour le ps n'était pas très
glorieux et voilà donc c'est un souvenir
de cette belle aventure parce que je
vais partager avec un beaucoup d'amis
voilà tellement jean luc mélenchon oui
que vous regrettez au parti socialiste
je le regretterai s'il avait disparu du
paysage politique comme adama il est
très présent
voilà donc je donc je donne je ne
regrette pas je pense toujours important
et utile mais vous saluer son parcours
depuis qu'il est sorti je peux pas les
missiles et du feu tenté de le suivre de
le rejoindre
donc pourquoi parce que je pense que
il a fait un choix politique qui est au
moment où il l'a fait ce parier sur une
sorte de dérive sociale libérale du
parti socialiste je n'ai jamais cru à
cela il a tenté de vous convaincre
non mais non militer dans un choix je
respecte je veux pas on n'est pas
d'accord là dessus
peu importe les jeudis s'il avait
disparu du paysage politique c'était une
très mauvaise nouvelle dès lors qu'il ne
disparaît pas du paysage politique qu'il
est un acteur important dont la voix
porte
moi j'ai du respect pour lui eu beaucoup
et ce qui l'est pas sur la voie du
social populisme jean luc mélenchon
enfin ça dépend pas ce qu'on attend pas
populisme moi je suis je savais qu'ils
étaient rangés dans la même rubrique pas
à monsieur duhamel est encore quelques
temps dans un essai d'éditoriaux c'est
parce qu'on parle au nom du peuple et
que le peuple réclamerait des réponses
rapides un stand de problèmes qui sont
assez urgent les salaires comme on paye
le loyer etc
si c'est ça je je prends avec lui je
revendique
et puis c'est une manière de mettre tout
le monde dans le même sac c'est à dire y
compris l'extrême droite une partie de
la gauche il ya un philosophe slovène
slavoj zizek qui dit à cette remarque
qui disait que le risque pour l'europe
ce serait de basculer dans une
opposition un conflit qui ne serait pas
entre la gauche et la droite mais en
forme de conte du centre centre gauche
au centre droit et tous les autres et on
ne saurait plus différencier la gauche
et la droite qu'à une forme de
comportement plus libertaire de la
gauche qui serait celui de la droite
mais un consensus sur les questions
économiques je trouve ce que ça ce
serait le drame et de la part de ceux
qui professent des solutions qui échoue
depuis 30 ans avec beaucoup de
régularité
je trouve que le avoir comme seul
argument de qualifier une caractérisée
comme des populistes
et surtout le sigma de leur propre aux
écoles intellectuelle alors comment
reconquérir alors les couches populaires
qui est pour l'instant font défaut comme
base électorale au parti socialiste
alors ça mériterait un bel exposé moi
j'ai écrit un bouquin où j'ai beaucoup
parlé de la prochaine
voyez où je vais beaucoup parlé de ça
fin août début septembre des noms mais
alors oui juste avant un bon moment
oui mais où justement je me concentrais
sur cette question ce qui est saisissant
c'est le scepticisme des classes
populaires sur la différence entre la
gauche et alors à ce que ça changera
quelque chose à ma vie il en doute et je
retourne sur la capacité la possibilité
pour les politiques d'influer tout
simplement sur leur vie en mieux et on
re quand on regarde le discours
politique on est forcé de constater
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des politiques
quand ils parlent ils disent si vous ne
faites pas ça ce sera pire c'est que la
seule perspective souvent qu'on propose
c'est pas une pause sportive en mieux
c'est dire attention si vous n'acceptez
pas prendre ce chemin nous vous disons
ce sera pire sur les retraites c'est est
emblématique
si vous n'acceptez pas à la retraite à
62 ans et à 67 ans il n'y aura plus
système par répartition donc ce sera
pire
sur tous les sujets c'est ce discours là
comme s'il y avait une fatalité
aujourd'hui à ce qu'on n'est pas le
choix de la direction que le peuple
français et le peuple allemand où le
peuple slovène où le peuple les tons
doit et peut prendre et je pense que la
réponse elle est justement dans la
différenciation politique entre la
gauche et la droite est dans la
démonstration que nous allons faire pas
simplement qu'on peut tenir un autre
discours
mais qu'on peut bien prendre ce chemin
différent sur la dette nous ne verrons
sur la question des déficits sur la
question du libre échange nous avons
qu'il ya une autre voie
mais sur la rencontre justement de ces
couches populaires dont on parlait ce
cas pas le risque aussi de courir
derrière le front national qui en a fait
sa cible prioritaire aujourd'hui mais
c'est une cible c'est une comment dire
c'était un vote par défaut la plupart du
temps fait
c'est une déclinaison du sarkozysme
marine le pen son programme en matière
d'immigration et d'insécurité qu'elle
propose en plus dur que sarkozy a déjà
échoué avec nicolas sarkozy
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que ces
deux visages deux politiques sont qui
appartient au même registre
ce que dit marine le pen est ce que met
en oeuvre déjà messieurs guéant monsieur
hier monsieur hortefeux
monsieur sarkozy monsieur fillon matière
d'immigration d'insécurité il se refuse
à s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes et et
moi je considère aujourd'hui que c'est
pas parce que marine le pen a tiré de
votre ouvriers a toujours eu du vote
ouvrier sur l'extrême droite ou sur la
droite que nous on devrait prendre acte
du vote structurelle à droite ou à
l'extrême droite dont l'abstention pour
considérer qu'on se désintéresse de ce
vote là au contraire c'est notre cible
politique pas notre cible au sens de
notre intérêt à nous mais c'est à eux
que nous voulons parler en premier c'est
à eux que nous voulons redonner foi en
leurs bulletins de vote
ça changera concrètement leurs
conditions de vie puis la part de celle
qui a jamais été sur les retraites pas
moi je dis un mot
marine le pen elle était ou sur les
retraites elle est ou sur les salaires
elle est ou dans les usines qui
délocalisent
elle est ou sur les plantes sociaux
candidate et parmi les noms les accords
mettent d'accord moi j'avais pas un
domestique dans le dos pour la pour
ménager les emmerdes ma vie voilà mais
en même temps qu'on tient un débat qui
est ouvert sur l'assistanat par exemple
lancé par laurent wauquiez vous le
refermer aussitôt parce que ça vous
dérange
pourquoi c'est un sujet très sensible
auprès des couches populaires on le
savait mais on referme pas du tout
qu'est ce qui dit le cancer c'est les
chômeurs ne me vous rebondissez ce thème
vous savez combien ses parents ce qu'on
consacre aux ars à 1,7 milliard d'euros
j'ai travaillé suffisamment débat quand
martin hirsch avait lancé le 1 7
milliard d'euros qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de donner en bouclier fiscal en
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune ou
au déjà riche en explique le cancer
c'est les chômeurs ses accès à eux à qui
on prête du vice de la part de monsieur
wauquiez
mais c'est juste que moi je dis et je la
subis si le problème de la france ce ne
sont pas ceux qui vivent des minima
sociaux
ça devrait être la priorité de la france
que leur proposer des solutions
et s'ils trouvent pas de boulot monsieur
wauquiez c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
volontaires d'être chauffeur
c'est pas parce qu'ils sont feignants
comme vous le
c est comme vous les montrer du doigt
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui non mais vous
lui monsieur wauquiez je ne peux pas
vous mais comme et que c'est aujourd'hui
parce qu'on est d'abord ya pas de
politique de l'emploi
d'abord parce qu'on a fait des
réductions d'impôts considérables qui
nous empêche d'investir et ces
réductions d'impôts ils ont profité à
qui d'abord j'ai à ceux qui payent des
impôts mais pas tous ceux qui payent des
impôts aux plus riches
donc merci pour les leçons et laurent
wauquiez quand je vous rappelle à l'hfr
quémander des aides pour son micro-parti
à londres auprès des chefs d'entreprise
qui avait beaucoup d'argent lui pour ça
ils allaient le faire et maintenant ils
demandent des sacrifices à ceux qui sont
au rsa
franchement il y en a bien un qui est
mal placé pour faire la leçon à qui que
ce soit c'est bien monsieur wauquiez le
plus jeune du gouvernement manifestement
sa tête c'est le plus vieux on enchaîne
revient un peu sur les photos dans votre
bureau il ya cette photo de barack obama
on a un peu quand même loin là aussi de
de votre positionnement politique
idéologique non qu'est ce qui représente
pour vous barack obama aux candidats 113
oui mais barack obama il assumer les
restrictions au libre échange pour
défendre les intérêts des industries
américaines et des ouvriers américains
intéressant barack obama la figure de la
modernité assume les restrictions
libre-échange ici on vous dit être
moderne c'est s'ouvrir à tous les vents
et par contre ne pas poser ce que sont
les intérêts des ouvriers des employés
français tous ceux qui travaillent ici
ou européen lui l'assument mais il est
moderne que c'est aux états unis les
restrictions au libre échange c'est
moderne pas ici ben moi je m'inspire
volontiers ses positionnements sur ce
point là ont été suffisamment critique
en europe et notamment en france et par
qui pas par moi pas par beaucoup de
socialistes qui propose rien de moins
qu'aujourd'hui à travers le juste
échange
une taxe aux frontières de l'europe qui
permettent d'alimenter un fonds destiné
aux pays en voie de développement
et bien ce qui est le principe d'une
taxe altruiste qui relève de la même
logique
et moi je suis content puis par ailleurs
au delà de tout ça moi quand même il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup de bonnes nouvelles
dans le monde occidental depuis
longtemps sinon ça son élection lui sa
naissance bientôt à l'elysée est ce que
ça peut être un argument politique le
bonheur conjugal balle d'abord
félicitations parce que c'est forcément
une nouvelle qui doit aller
remplir de joie parce que c'est un
enfant moi je nous parle de politique
c'est d'abord un acte d'amour donc moi
je
si c'est vrai parce qu'ils ne l'ont pas
confirmé même je crois félicitations à
tous les deux et aprem je crois pas que
je pense pas ou je n'espère pas que
qu'ils joueront là dessus d'abord parce
que je pense qu'ils sont convaincus
l'un et l'autre que devant ce serait pas
très correct mais au plus que ça n'aura
que les français votent pas là-dessus
quoi mais les français en plein scandale
dsk apprécié sans doute l' annonce que
ce
bonheur conjugal sera concrétisée par
une naissance touché une française bref
un autre sans comparaison
je vous rappelle qu'il ya toujours la
présomption d'innocence bien sûr voilà
toujours la présomption d'innocence j'ai
encore quand même une question sur ce
sujet mais dans mes joues en continu -
vous venez de faire la bla parallèle de
rue et continuer j'ai pas fini vous
allez vous vous esquivez un petit peu
vite
donc non mais moi je trouve que c'est
tissé ces deux images n'ont rien à voir
est ce pour ça que dans un cas je suis
mobilisé comme temps par socialiste et
j'ai dû céder ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure et dans l'autre cas je félicite
ce couple le couple précis maison s'il
attend un ou deux enfants puisse avoir
c'est en tout cas ce sont des titres qui
s'entrechoquent à la une de l'actualité
benoît hamon j'ai encore une question
fait si le hasard
oui c'est le hasard c'est le hasard vous
y croyez encore une question sur l'
affaire dsk on a mentionné tout à
l'heure votre engagement auprès des
mouvements féministes sincère de longue
date benoît hamon quand vous entendez
aujourd'hui que les avocats de dsk
pourraient utiliser l'argument
dans une relation consentie de la part
de la jeune femme
ça doit vous faire bondir mais on
connaît pas le dos il est d'accord on
doit être connue des joueurs mais quand
même
mais jusqu'au stade de l'est de la ville
écoutez c'est possible c'est possible
c'est possible je sais juste que
l'électorat féminin se prononcera en
fonction
pour ce les femmes de ce qu'elles sont
leur condition de femme aussi de ceux
qui peuvent améliorer leur condition de
femme en termes d'émancipation
d'épanouissement
je crois qu'aujourd'hui quand le parti
socialiste prend l'engagement en cinq
ans d'opérer un rattrapage a juste bla
bla bla sur les inégalités de salaires
dans le salaire des femmes et des hommes
en faisant dans la transparence dans les
entreprises sur qui gagne quoi alors de
sérieuses surprise dans certaines
entreprises
j'espère que dans cette oreille ici même
on se découvrir mais oui on sait jamais
mais josiane mois et bat en tout cas ça
c'est un engagement concret après salem
moi j'ai vu entendu les mouvements
féministes et je trouve qu'elles sont
naturellement dans leurs engagements et
en tant que socialiste je suis aussi
féministe par définition
merci à vous merci père une bonne soirée
à la semaine prochaine